hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
from my flash bonus video I wanted to
talk all about time travel in the DC
Universe and how the TV show is going to
deal with it we're still a little ways
away but we're going to see that play
out in the next couple of episodes like
the way they're going to visualize time
travel on the flash in the context of
the comics the flash uses the Speed
Force to time travel so I'm going to
start with a history of time travel in
the comics relative to the flash and
then I'll talk about how I think the TV
show is going to deal with it
so right off the bat there are a couple
really important ideas there's time
travel specifically obviously seen a lot
of time travel movies a lot of stories
that are dealt with it
there's the speedforce and then there's
the DC Multiverse
in the older comics like Golden Age
Silver Age time travel was used to allow
characters to cross over so you get
Justice League interacting with
characters from different titles and
they would use time travel as a way to
accomplish that or to send characters on
wacky adventures as DC grew they started
to talk more and more about the idea of
a multiverse so you could explain why
there were different versions of
different characters this worked for a
while but eventually continuity became a
big issue DC decided to simplify
everything so they had crisis on
Infinite Earths and they collapsed
everything to a single continuity if you
ever read flashpoint paradox this is the
exact same thing like they took the
Wildstorm vertigo and main DC universes
and just combined them onto one shared
continuity obviously convergence right
now that's like the current DC comic
book event this summer
that's undoing all that so we're going
back to multiverse but you get the idea
time-travel multiverse all used to deal
with IP the one character that kind of
fit naturally into this idea of jumping
between worlds jumping around in time
was the flash because of the Speed Force
the origins of the Speed Force are still
a little vague it's this extra
dimensional energy source that
supposedly grew out of Jack Kirby's idea
of the quote-unquote source that's an
idea that was born in his fourth world
comic books also known as the New Gods
that's also kind of the way DC has
explained it's metahumans in that the
energy that gives them their metahuman
abilities originates from the source the
quote-unquote source the TV show has
simplified that they're just going with
the idea of dark matter so for all
intents and purposes when the flash is
accessing the Speed Force on the TV show
he's accessing that extra dimension
Dark Matter that's where things get a
little timey wimey because you know the
types of powers the flash can have just
depend on what the writers want him to
do so obviously the TV show just going
to simplify these things don't worry
about it too much for now but but
essentially think of the Speed Force as
allowing the flash to time travel via
wormhole theory it's like the Speed
Force is this space-time train depot
that allows you to go to any point in
time you want to but in order to get
into the train depot you have to achieve
a certain velocity that only the flash
family is capable of and that that
includes all the reverse flashes - there
have been a lot of different reverse
flashes in the comics but all of them
time travel using the Speed Force it's
just the way they access the Speed Force
is a little bit different like there's
the cosmic treadmill they're just
flat-out running super fast it's all
based on the Speed Force on the TV show
Harrison wells sacrificed his tachyon
device that was supposed to give him the
ability to time travel so they might
turn Cisco's souped-up treadmill into
the cosmic treadmill from the comics and
use it that way that would be really
awesome but I'm not expecting it there
been a couple descriptions online about
the flash in the reverse-flash achieving
you know super velocity and
time-traveling I don't know if those are
true or not so I'm just going to wait
and see what the TV show does at their
core all flash stories are time-travel
stories you can think of time as a
circle but the interesting thing is is
where did the circle start if the flash
in the reverse flash have been battling
across space and time when did the fight
start and on the TV show if we're going
through time loops which loop is this
like is this Barry prime is this the
first Barry or has the reverse flash
gone back in time several times to
change the past it can be really
confusing causality loop but for all
intents and purposes I think the TV show
is just doing the simplest version and
we're seeing Barry Prime even though the
reverse flash is the one that started
this war it's a very chicken or the egg
argument you know did Barry Allen come
first become the flash inspire the
reverse flash to become the reverse
flash or did it happen in a different
order so let's let's look at the comics
just going back to professor zooms
origin story so I'm going to go with the
Jeff John's origin story for a abarth on
it's pretty faithful to the first origin
story from the Silver Age comics just
because professor zoom is from the
Silver Age he just added a lot more
logic to it so it makes more sense on
paper in order to make a o'Barr Thawne a
little more
pathetic Geoff Johns tells him as being
born in the 25th century which is
basically like the Ned Flanders version
of the future imagine the most boring
vanilla planned-out thing ever there's
no such thing as accidents or
unpredictability even time itself is
governed so like everything you do every
moment of your day pre-plan set out
ahead of time I know it sounds really
dystopian which is why a Abarth on
rebels this is this is all bullcrap as
he starts to grow up he learns about the
flashes and their ability to bend
space-time but in the future in the 25th
century
there aren't any speedsters there's no
one left alive that can access the Speed
Force so slowly over time he learns how
to access the Speed Force and recreate
the accident that created the Barry
Allen flash but it gets a little timey
wimey because as he grows up
periodically like when big events in his
life happened things that change the
course of his life this shadowy figure
that looks like the reverse-flash
appears and changes things eventually he
grows to adulthood and finds a time
capsule like one just appears in front
of him with Barry Allen's flash suit
because the suit came into direct
contact with the Speed Force air bar
Thawne is able to recreate that accident
that created the Barry Allen flash and
he gains his Speed Force powers he
reverse engineers the flash
thus he becomes the reverse flash based
on the way Geoff Johns lays it out it
seems like at some point in his future
air bar Thawne gets the reverse flash
powers and then loops back on his own
timeline to help himself
gain those powers faster it's kind of
like watching a bowling ball roll down
towards the pins air bar Thawne wants a
strike but he throws it in the wrong
direction so he just like jumps in at
different points in time to correct the
course of the ball so that it hits the
strike eventually he becomes a criminal
the flash stops him but the reverse
flash needs Barry Allen to become the
flash so that he can become the reverse
flash in the future so they're stuck in
this loop as time goes by the reverse
flashes plans get grander and grander
until he concocts flashpoint an
alternate timeline where Barry Allen
never became the flash and the reverse
flash a-ah Barth on is the sole
possessor of the Speed Force it gets way
more complicated than that but just you
know in the simplest of terms the
reverse flash goes back in time change
is something the flash fixes it
then the
reverse-flash goes back again and again
and again and again you get the idea
eventually they tease out the idea of
the butterfly effect berry learns that
even changing small things in the past
will have universe shattering
consequences in the future remember when
Joe said learn to accept the things that
I can't change so no matter how fast
berry can run there are some things that
he won't be able to change so like I
said there are a bunch of different
versions of the reverse-flash
but they all use the Speed Force to
time-travel we just we haven't got to
the point on the show where berry can
access the Speed Force itself we can
physically travel into the Speed Force
if you remember Martin Stein described
it as the highway the Speed Force is the
highway Barry just can't get on it yet
so he can't time travel until he can
take the on-ramp
that just means running faster and
faster one of the really fun things that
the producers have said though is that
when they do start to do time-travel
stuff they will pay homage to a lot of
the classic time-travel stories like
Back to the Future Terminator like they
already joked about on the show Doctor
Who
Groundhogs Day really like funny sad
horrifying stories all at the same time
my favorite time-travel stories are
Doctor Who of course as you as you can
guess by all the Doctor Who videos on my
channel grande hogs date back to the
future terminator like cisco jokes and
then there's more hardcore stuff like
time crimes and primer those are awesome
movies if you want like a really
scientific in-depth look that goes into
the logic of time-travel primer is your
best bet but it's also the hardest to
follow it is excruciating in its detail
and its analysis of time-travel
here's my big question for you guys when
the show does get into time travel do
you want to see them do a flashpoint
paradox type storyline I think it's a
really interesting idea but in order to
accomplish it I think that they would
have to keep it relatively
self-contained I don't think they're
going to do any storyline that's going
to make the arrow writers or the writers
of this spin-off show have to
incorporate flash stuff into it so if
something happens to change the universe
inside the flash like in the finale or
something like that or even in season
two I think that they'll have to fix it
within that same episode otherwise
they'd have to do a whole bunch of
explainers on arrow in this new spin-off
show just in the name of sanity I think
the show will try to keep its
time-travel stories relatively
self-contained to the flash so that you
know arrow doesn't have to deal with it
just to get you guys a little more
pumped Rick cause net posted this
picture from behind the scenes of him
hanging out with the reverse-flash
theory craft all you want I think I'm
going to save that for next
flash video they're just starting to
film the last couple of episodes to that
end we have to remember that iris West
is going to be investigating STAR Labs
which means that eventually Eddie Thawne
is going to cross paths with Harrison
wells more if you guys have written any
flash comics you kind of see where I'm
going with this I think they're going to
share a relationship that's going to
look something like a bar Thawne and
hunter zolomon just in general when your
theory crafting remember that the TV
show is blending the Wally West stories
with the Barry Allen stories I think for
next week's bonus flash video I'll
probably do like a villain character
video just because it's been a while
since I talked about big flash villains
they've already picked it up for season
two for those that don't know the flash
has been picked up for season two so
there's going to be a whole bunch of new
villains they can bring in what you guys
wait for that next video you can click
here to learn all about Batman a death
in the family in the comics I just do
explain it for the comic book storyline
and you can click here to catch up with
all my age of Ultron videos thanks so
much for watching now let's all do the
thing
you